in this video we'll create a new
loopback project to record customer
information to MongoDB first run API C
loop back to create an application and
enter a name when prompted in this demo
I'll name eight customers select the
default options but when asked about the
kind of application choose an empty
server
change into the customers directory and
run npm install route back
- connector - MongoDB - - save to
install and save the connector which
will allow our application to speak with
MongoDB after we setup our datasource
next run API C edit to open the API
designer in your browser click login
with bluemix then use your bluemix
credentials to login now let's create a
data source which will configure our
connection to the database click the
data sources tab then the + button and
enter a meaningful name for the data
source I'm naming mine MongoDB in the
next form fill in the necessary
configuration information such as the
host and port of your database
then click the diskette in the upper
right to save and test the connection to
the data source we just defined let's go
create a model now click models and then
the + button to add a new model I'll
name this model customer since we'll use
it to store customer information set the
data source to the name of the data
source created earlier in my case
MongoDB the public checkbox indicates to
our application that we would like it to
create a REST API for this model click
the plus button in the lower-right to
add a property to your model I'll add
first name last name and zip code I want
to be sure my application always
includes these properties so I'll check
the required box next to all of them
also notice that I can select the type
for the property this will ensure zip
code will always be a number and the
names will always be strings click the
diskette in the upper right to save
let's try out our new API click the play
arrow in the lower left this starts a
local instance of your application and
micro gateway so that you can try out
your application locally now let's
investigate our new API hit Explorer
then we'll use the post customers API to
create new customer entries click the
generate link in the parameters field to
generate a ran
entry based on the model we made I can
click call operation to save the model
to the database I'll create one more
entry and edit the zip code field I can
then go to get customers API to get a
list of all the customers in my database
that concludes our tutorial of the
basics of loop back data sources thanks
for watching